now Turkey's largest city Istanbul is
preparing for a rerun of its mayoral
election in a few weeks time the
country's Electoral Commission annulled
the result of an earlier vote following
a complaint from President Recep type
Edwin's a kay party his party lost the
election to Ekrem Imam Oulu who
represented an alliance of opposition
parties now elsewhere in Turkey it's not
uncommon that candidates who have won an
election are prevented from taking up
their positions
our correspondent Yulia Hahn visited the
Kurdish majority city of Van she met a
woman there who won her local election
back in March but hasn't yet been able
to start serving as mayor when do John
Koch mass walked through her
neighborhood in the city of van it
always takes a while she's constantly
recognized by people involved in
conversations asked for advice it's
hardly surprising many here think of
Kuchma's as their mayor in Turkey's
local elections at the end of March she
stood for the pro-kurdish opposition
party HTP in vans ID limit district she
won with almost 54% of the vote but her
joy did not last long Jessica Kennedy's
the malls I never thought that I would
not receive my mandate I wasn't
expecting this because the Election
Commission had approved me as a
candidate two months after the vote
people here are still appalled by the
election Board's decision I think this
is very unfair is wrong whoever wins the
election should take office giving her
the mandate they're stealing the will of
the people most women the Election
Commission says gojong Kuchma's should
not be mayor because she was dismissed
from her job by an emergency decree
following the attempted coup in 2016
despite international criticism the
Turkish government had tens of thousand
of state employees detained sacked or
suspended Eugen Kuchma's was a teacher
at the time was also on the list she
still doesn't know why the same election
authority that allowed us to run as
candidates then makes this unlawful
decision it's supposed to be an
absolutely independent institution but
it's not it's under the control of the
AKP William Sadler instead of Kuchma's
the runner-up candidate in her district
was declared mayor a member of President
Edwin's ake a party a few weeks ago
Kuchma's protested against a ruling in
front of the town hall where she feels
she should now be working it took just a
few minutes for the police to clear the
demonstrators
[Applause]
hi Ola tarnish is the only member of the
ruling AKP and van who was willing to
talk to us he blames Googe on Kuchma's
party for the outcome rival party
deliberately nominated candidates who
were sacked by emergency decrees our
honourable President had warned them
don't nominate people with links to
terror groups or crime or those who were
sacked if you do it this is what you
can't in five districts in southeastern
Turkey AKP politicians were given the
office despite pro-kurdish HDP
candidates actually winning the
elections the opposition insists it's a
deliberate attempt to keep them out of
power
jujin catchments is now helping out in
her husband stationery store she has
filed an appeal against the decision to
withdraw her mandate even though she has
little chance of success I don't want to
give up I want to be there for the
people of edremit I hope that the
unlawful and anti-democratic practices
in Turkey will soon end a present from a
friend a nameplate for what should have
been her new office now it's here in the
shop one of the few reminders that Googe
on cosmas was recently elected mayor